This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. IKEA Hacking. Is what we've been doing. And this is friend of the show Sean Cole. And yes, he said IKEA Hacking. I feel good about it. It feels a little bit subversive. And a little bit bourgeois. It's like being a punk member of the mainstream. Given that our audience is, you know, our audience, you probably heard of IKEA hacking.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。宜家改造（IKEA Hacking）。这就是我们一直在做的事情。这位是节目的老朋友肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）。没错，他说的是“宜家改造”。我对此感觉不错。这感觉有点颠覆性，又有点小资。就像是主流文化中的朋克成员。考虑到我们的听众，你知道的，我们的听众，你可能听说过宜家改造。
It's the practice of buying stuff from IKEA and then re-engineering it, hacking it, into customized, more functional and often just way better designed stuff. In Sean's case, that stuff is three, five foot high shelves. Sean has decided upon the Calix variety. Plus two very heavy wooden doors from Home Depot, all of which he is drilling and screwing and bolting together into one big beautiful queen size, Frankenstein storage bed, to cure his basement-less New York City existence. one big, beautiful, queen-sized, Frankenstein storage bed to cure his basement-less New York City existence.
这是一种购买宜家产品，然后对其进行重新设计、改造，将其变成定制化、功能更强，且往往设计得更好的物品的做法。在肖恩的案例中，这些物品是三个五英尺高的书架。肖恩选择了卡莱克（Kallax）系列。再加上两扇来自家得宝（Home Depot）的厚重木门，他正在把所有这些东西钻孔、拧螺丝、用螺栓固定在一起，做成一张巨大、漂亮、像弗兰肯斯坦怪人一样的储物床，以解决他那没有地下室的纽约市生活困境。
We are finishing the construction of the third Calix shelf. We become expert Calix assemblers. The locus of the IKEA Hacking Movement is a website called IKEAHacker's.net. It's a showcase for those who would trick out their callxes, their arkelstorps, their flard fools. They can both gather tips from their hackers and, more importantly, boast pictures of their
我们正在完成第三个卡莱克书架的组装。我们成了卡莱克组装专家。宜家改造运动的中心是一个叫 IKEAHacker's.net 的网站。它是那些想要改装他们的卡莱克、阿克尔斯托普（Arkelstorp）、弗拉德（Flard）家具的人的展示平台。他们不仅可以从其他改造者那里收集技巧，更重要的是，还可以炫耀他们
own hacks and even a step-by-step guide to how they made them. IKEAHacker's.net has been in the news a lot lately, and not for happy reasons. You might have read those stories online. We're going to get into all that later. But first, I wanted to introduce you to my hacker partner in crime, Jonathan Bean. Four bolts and one wrench. He's an assistant professor at Bucknell University. Back in 2009, he co-wrote a serious academic paper about IKEA hacking with Danielle Rossner,
自己的改造作品，甚至提供他们制作过程的分步指南。IKEAHacker's.net 最近经常出现在新闻中，而且不是因为什么好事。你可能在网上读到过那些报道。我们稍后会详细讨论这些。但首先，我想向大家介绍我的改造搭档，乔纳森·比恩（Jonathan Bean）。四颗螺栓一把扳手。他是巴克内尔大学（Bucknell University）的助理教授。早在2009年，他就和丹妮拉·罗斯纳（Danielle Rossner）合写了一篇关于宜家改造的严肃学术论文，
who now teaches design at the University of Washington. And they got interested in part because of how bendable the term IKEA hacking is. Here's Jonathan. There was so much when you scratched the surface about what IKEA hacking could be. It could be anything from, I bought this shelf at IKEA and it was an inch too long for my closet, so I cut an inch off of it. Or could be where you just take a say a salad bowl and make it into a light. And this is Daniella. Right, that's not even actually changing the object itself, it's just changing its use. And at the other
她现在在华盛顿大学教授设计。他们之所以产生兴趣，部分是因为“宜家改造”这个词的定义非常灵活。这是乔纳森。当你深入挖掘宜家改造的含义时，会发现它涵盖的内容非常广泛。它可以是任何事情，比如“我在宜家买了这架子，但它比我的壁橱长了一英寸，所以我把它切掉了一英寸”。或者也可以是你拿一个沙拉碗把它做成一盏灯。这是丹妮拉。没错，那甚至不是在改变物体本身，只是改变了它的用途。而在
end of the spectrum, an artist named Sandra von Wussel did a very provocative work of art, which is an IKEA chair reconfigured to look like a stirrup from a kind of college's office. So, and both of these things fall under the rubric of IKEA hacking. That's a really wide rubric. And now please put your hands over your children's ears for 20 seconds. I really like the IKEA Love Toy as another example where you take it. IKEA Love Toy as another example where you take a IKEA Love Toy a Love Toy made of the
光谱的另一端，一位名叫桑德拉·冯·伍塞尔（Sandra von Wussel）的艺术家做了一件非常有挑衅意味的艺术品，那是一把被重新配置成看起来像某种大学办公室里的马镫的宜家椅子。所以，这两件事都属于宜家改造的范畴。这个范畴真的很广。现在请捂住孩子们的耳朵20秒。我真的很喜欢“宜家爱之玩具”（IKEA Love Toy）作为另一个例子，你拿它……宜家爱之玩具作为另一个例子，你拿一个宜家爱之玩具，一个由
Orm song shoot trees and an IKEA product that's the milk frothing device so taking those together and making a little vibrator This is a much racier interview than I was expecting And the hacker Rade aren't just diverse in terms of their sensibility. They're diverse in the most basic way possible. You see Hacks posted from all over this country and from Australia, Russia, Israel, Dubai. Someone posted a Hacks that's a French country house library in an actual French country house. He used 60 billion beno bookcases and he has these before and after pictures
奥姆（Orm）系列树木和宜家的一款奶泡机组成的爱之玩具，把它们组合在一起做成一个小振动器。这比我预期的采访要大胆得多。而且改造者们不仅在感性上是多元的。他们在最基本的层面上也是多元的。你会看到来自全国各地，以及澳大利亚、俄罗斯、以色列、迪拜的改造作品。有人发布了一个改造作品，那是一个真正的法国乡村别墅里的法式乡村图书馆。他用了60个比利（Billy）书架，他有这些改造前后的照片，
and explained all how he did it. Because everything's exactly the same at IKEA, no matter where you are, it sort of lowers the barriers to recreating something. Because this is the thing. Say I wanted to teach you, Roman, how to build a workbench. But you live in Germany and I live in the US.
并解释了他所有的做法。因为宜家的一切在世界各地都是完全一样的，这在某种程度上降低了重新创造某样东西的门槛。因为这就是关键所在。假设我想教你，罗曼，如何建造一个工作台。但你住在德国，我住在美。
If you go and buy a stud, a wood stud at a home depot in the US, it's gonna be an inch and a half by three and a half inches. If you go and buy a wood stud at Bauhaus, which is German home improvement store, it's going to be a different size. Wait, to tell me I'm not dreaming and he just said that there's a German home improvement store
如果你去美国的家得宝买一根木柱，它的大小会是1.5英寸乘以3.5英寸。如果你去Bauhaus买一根木柱，那是一家德国的家居装修店，它的大小会是不同的。等等，告诉我我不是在做梦，他刚才说有一家德国的家居装修店
called Bauhaus. Yes, but it's actually Swiss. That's so fantastic. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming.
叫Bauhaus？是的，但它其实是瑞士的。这太棒了。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。
I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming.
我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。
I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. I'm not dreaming. That's what's allowing this global community of hackers to thrive. So if I posted a Nike hack in Boston and someone in the Netherlands saw it, they could probably reproduce it using the pieces at their local store, much like a Lego kit. Make no mistake, the actual posts themselves showing your work. That's a huge part of this whole thing.
我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。我不是在做梦。这就是让这个全球改造者社区蓬勃发展的原因。所以如果我在波士顿发布了一个宜家改造作品，而荷兰有人看到了，他们很可能可以使用当地商店的零件复制它，就像乐高积木一样。别误会，展示你作品的实际帖子本身。那是整个事情中非常重要的一部分。
I think that there is something to this feeling of recognition. Like, it's, you're not creative unless you recognize it's being creative. Yeah. If, if IKEA is hacked in a forest, does it make a sound? Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Hey dolls, it's theater here and I have officially done my first IKEA hack. I'm gonna show you how I'm gonna do it. IKEA hack! My first IKEA hack! So we've got an Ikea piece that will be modifying. And as you might expect, there's a lot of this kind of hacking and showing and telling on YouTube too. By now the search term shouldn't be too mysterious. Ikea hack.
我认为这种被认可的感觉是有意义的。就像，除非你意识到这是创造力，否则你就不是在进行创造。是的。如果宜家在森林里被改造了，它会发出声音吗？是的。完全正确。是的。嘿，伙计们，我是西奥（Theater），我正式完成了我的第一次宜家改造。我要向你们展示我是怎么做的。宜家改造！我的第一次宜家改造！所以我们有一个要修改的宜家产品。正如你所料，YouTube上也有很多这种改造和展示的视频。现在这个搜索词应该不神秘了。宜家改造。
And we are checking out her beautiful Ikea transformation pieces, which I like to call them. You call them hack jobs. Hack jobs. I'll show you how to customize. You wear a Kia's Halsa armchair. I'm gonna go measure how far my elbows are up in relation to this desk. Now let's put on the marble contact paper onto the top of the table. Okay and there we have our installed six inch cabinet. So now we have a really cool shoe locker. You don't know if it's for my Kia. It could be. It might not be.
我们正在查看她美丽的宜家改造作品，我喜欢称它们为“改造作品”。你称它们为“黑活儿”（Hack jobs）。黑活儿。我会向你展示如何定制。你穿的是宜家的Halsa扶手椅。我要去测量我的手肘相对于这张桌子有多高。现在让我们把大理石纹接触纸贴到桌面上。好了，我们安装好了六英寸的柜子。所以现在我们有了一个非常酷的鞋柜。你不知道它是不是来自宜家。可能是。也可能不是。
For $44 worth of parts for my key, I could be, it might not be. For $44 with the parts for my key, but what I've done, I mean, if they're good enough to do some frankly pretty remarkable things with these materials, like why aren't they just going and buying raw lumber and screws and nails and hammering together something maybe more lasting and less press-bordy? Well, they're not just hacking the materials, right? They're hacking IKEA. They're hacking the brand. They're hacking what that brand actually symbolizes beyond just the stores.
花44美元买的宜家零件，可能是，也可能不是。花44美元买的宜家零件，但我所做的是，我的意思是，如果他们有能力用这些材料做出一些坦率地说非常了不起的事情，为什么他们不直接去买原始木材、螺丝和钉子，然后敲打出一些可能更持久、不那么像刨花板的东西呢？好吧，他们不仅仅是在改造材料，对吧？他们是在改造宜家。他们是在改造这个品牌。他们是在改造这个品牌除了商店之外所象征的意义。
Or put another way to quote Daniel and Jonathan, they're mocking the modularity of IKEA. Saying this stuff is so tinkertoy, I can mix and mash up the hell out of IKEA. Saying this stuff is so tinker toy, I can mix and mash up the hell out of it. And it also goes back to that homogeneity, right? That if this is the McDonald's of furniture, I'm going to go against the grain and make a double, triple, extra pickle big Mac with no middle bun in it. Right, it's part of your identity at that point. You're saying, I'm a person who transforms things, but this is where it gets even more complicated
或者换句话说，引用丹妮拉和乔纳森的话，他们是在嘲弄宜家的模块化。说这些东西太像儿童玩具了，我可以把宜家的东西混合搭配得乱七八糟。说这些东西太像儿童玩具了，我可以把它们混合搭配得乱七八糟。这也回到了那种同质性，对吧？如果这是家具界的麦当劳，我要反其道而行之，做一个没有中间面包层的双层、三层、多加酸黄瓜的巨无霸。没错，在那一点上，这是你身份的一部分。你是在说，我是一个改造事物的人，但这就是事情变得更复杂的地方
according to Jonathan. Within that group of people who wanted to completely transform something, some of them really wanted to maintain the AQI aesthetic. So they would say, well, this is something we want to say that could have come from AQI but didn't. So there's a sort of sense of, sure, you want to express yourself, but you're also trying to sort of outdo the doer. Like you're trying to outwit IKEA, right? Right. Out IKEA, IKEA.
根据乔纳森的说法。在那些想要彻底改造某样东西的人群中，有些人确实想保持宜家的美学。所以他们会说，好吧，这是我们想说的一件本可以来自宜家但实际上不是的东西。所以有一种感觉，当然，你想表达自己，但你也在试图超越创造者。就像你试图智取宜家，对吧？没错。比宜家更宜家。
All right, now we're going to lay the shelves down on their sides in a way that IKEA did not intend. We now rejoin this IKEA hack already in progress. To catch everyone up, we have built three Cadillac's shelves for mykea. We've laid them down on their sides in a kind of U. It's like my bed is a whale skeleton lying on its side and you're gonna be putting stuff in the rib cage of the skeleton.
好了，现在我们要把书架侧放，以宜家原本不打算的方式。我们现在回到这个正在进行中的宜家改造。为了让大家跟上进度，我们已经为我的宜家项目建造了三个卡莱克书架。我们把它们侧放成一个U型。就像我的床是一具侧卧的鲸鱼骨架，而你将把东西放进骨架的肋骨里。
That's what I'm going to be like. And we're gonna put doors, really heavy doors on top of the shelves as whereas where I'm going to lay down, go to sleepy by. You sound like an insane person. I know. I know. You're like Aquaman standing on top of a wild marine creature. This is, but this is what it's like. It's like, it's like, taming, you know. It's like taming the most placid beast in the known universe and Ikea shelf on its side. No, that's, but this is what I'm saying. This is, it isn't placid. It's us that is usually the placid.
我就会是那个样子。我们要把门，非常重的门放在书架上面，那是我要躺下睡觉的地方。你听起来像个疯子。我知道。我知道。你就像站在海洋生物身上的海王。这是，但这确实是这种感觉。这就像，驯服，你知道的。这就像驯服已知宇宙中最温顺的野兽，一个侧放的宜家书架。不，那是，但这正是我想说的。这，它并不温顺。通常温顺的是我们。
Uh, okay, this is the best part. We're about to drill unsanctioned holes into a piece of a key. You're not sure. You're not going to take it back. You want to have it out of it. Oh, actually, yeah. Man, do the honors. Sure. So why is this your favorite part? I mean, I think it's just that for the longest time, you know, you're told that drilling holes where they're not supposed to go is destructive and wrong. And we were doing that, and it's still transgressive and you're crossing a boundary, but it's not a destruction anymore.
呃，好吧，这是最棒的部分。我们要在一个宜家产品上钻一些未经批准的孔。你不确定。你不能把它退回去了。你想从中得到它。哦，实际上，是的。伙计，你来做这个荣誉。当然。那么为什么这是你最喜欢的部分？我的意思是，我认为这只是因为在很长一段时间里，你知道，你被告知在不该钻孔的地方钻孔是破坏性的和错误的。而我们正在那样做，这仍然是越界的，你正在跨越边界，但这不再是破坏了。
It's creation. It felt like for once I wasn't just saying, what's out there, which one on the menu do I want? We were making what we wanted. Yeah, but you were making what we wanted. Yeah, but you were still shopping at IKEA. True. Well, it's interesting, IKEA's response to this, right? It's not to shut down IKEA hackers.
这是创造。感觉就像我终于不再只是说，外面有什么，菜单上我想要哪一个？我们正在制造我们想要的东西。是的，但你仍然是在宜家购物。确实。嗯，宜家对此的反应很有趣，对吧？他们并没有关闭宜家改造者。
Again, this is Daniela Rossner, who co-wrote that IKEA hacking paper. There's a lot more, almost support for hacking within the corporate world than there was, you know, five or six years ago. And I think part of that is corporations seeing that this adds to the process of kind of buying and recognizing the products. And yes, this is the moment in the story where we do the ironic tape to tape juxtaposition.
再次说明，这是丹妮拉·罗斯纳，她合写了那篇宜家改造论文。在企业界，对改造的支持几乎比五六年前多了很多。我认为部分原因是企业看到这增加了购买和认可产品的过程。是的，这就是故事中我们进行讽刺性磁带对比的时刻。
Maestro? Earlier this week, Swedish flatpack furniture manufacturer Ikea dealt a massive blow to the long-running fan blog IkeaHackers.net. According to a blog post published by Founder Jewel's Yapp, the site was issued a cease-and-desist order in March, alleging this. This is the news that we alluded to at the beginning. Around the same time that Sean and Jonathan were hacking together his bed, unbeknownst to them, a brand protection company wrote to the Queen Bee of IKEA HACTIM, the woman who runs IKEAHacker's .NET, Jewels YAP. Jewels isn't her real first name. The
大师？本周早些时候，瑞典平板包装家具制造商宜家对长期运营的粉丝博客IkeaHackers.net造成了沉重打击。据创始人朱尔斯·雅普（Jules Yapp）发表的一篇博文称，该网站在三月份收到了停止侵权通知，指控如下。这就是我们在开头提到的新闻。就在肖恩和乔纳森一起改造他的床的同时，他们不知道的是，一家品牌保护公司写信给了宜家改造界的“女王蜂”，运营IKEAHacker's.NET的女性，朱尔斯·雅普。朱尔斯不是她真正的名字。这封
letter basically said that IKEA was not amused, and that if Jewels didn't stop operating her website the way she was, she could be in big trouble. Hey, Jewels. Hi. Hi. How are you? I'm good. How are you? It wasn't until the news broke about the cease and desist letter that Jules agreed to talk to me. Yes. She lives in Malaysia when we talked by Skype. Before we got down to business, I was just curious how she thought up the site. So I was checking out a few home decor websites and I found a few IT hacks that were scattered around on the internet. And then that was when I thought,
信基本上说宜家很不高兴，如果朱尔斯不停止以这种方式运营她的网站，她可能会有大麻烦。嘿，朱尔斯。嗨。嗨。你好吗？我很好，你呢？直到关于停止侵权信的新闻传出，朱尔斯才同意和我交谈。是的。我们通过Skype交谈时，她住在马来西亚。在进入正题之前，我只是好奇她是怎么想到这个网站的。所以我当时正在查看一些家居装饰网站，发现互联网上散布着一些宜家改造的案例。然后就在那时我想，
how great it would be if I could see all these hacks in one place. No, and that was when Tara, the light box, just ran on and I knew I had to start it. So that was in 2006. And for some reason, only this year, 2014, March 12th to be precise, did jewels get an email? With the subject line IQ hackers,
如果我能把所有这些改造案例放在同一个地方，那该多好。不，就在那时，塔拉（Tara），那个灯箱，刚刚运行起来，我就知道我必须开始做这件事了。那是2006年。出于某种原因，直到今年，2014年3月12日，准确地说，朱尔斯才收到一封电子邮件？主题行是“宜家改造者，
notification of violation of trademark rights. Wow. Wow. So I felt my blood drain literally, you know, it was scary. So what did they want her to do? Hand over the domain name, stop using the IKEA trade marker,
侵犯商标权的通知”。哇。哇。所以我感觉我的血都凉了，真的，你知道，这很可怕。那么他们想让她做什么？交出域名，停止使用宜家商标，
anything trade marked by IKEA, which I think means even pictures of the furniture, and she'd have to close down her Twitter and Facebook accounts to and all the social media stuff. The thing that's ironic about this, the thing that I didn't understand right away was that Jules loves IKEA. I mean, she's just a huge fan.
任何宜家注册商标的东西，我想这意味着甚至包括家具的照片，而且她还得关闭她的Twitter和Facebook账户，以及所有的社交媒体账号。这件事讽刺的地方在于，我一开始没明白的是，朱尔斯热爱宜家。我的意思是，她是一个超级粉丝。
I am, I guess. Superfan. It strikes me that it's like meeting a celebrity that you've always really loved and like that celebrity is really mean to you in some way. Yes, yeah, that was fast-closed, you know? I just felt like after that, you know. I had been given a restraining order by the celebrity. After Jules announced on her website that big changes might be coming to IKEA hackers,
我想我是。超级粉丝。这让我觉得就像见到了一位你一直非常喜爱的名人，而那位名人以某种方式对你非常刻薄。是的，是的，那真是太快了，你知道？在那之后我只是感觉……我被那位名人下达了限制令。在朱尔斯在她的网站上宣布宜家改造者可能会发生重大变化之后，
the story went viral. People were pretty pissed off. Cory Doctoro, who blogs on Boyn Boyn, famously called the cease-and-assist letter, quote, steaming a bullsh** and quote. But at this point, Jewels was pretty much resigned. She thought the best thing she could do was just to comply and then transfer the hacks over
这个故事疯传开来。人们非常生气。在Boing Boing上写博客的科里·多克托罗（Cory Doctorow）著名地称这封停止侵权信为“彻头彻尾的胡扯”。但此时，朱尔斯已经基本认命了。她认为她能做的最好的事情就是遵守规定，然后把改造案例转移
to another site, which didn't have IKEA's name on it. If nothing else, she was just grateful that so many people reacted so strongly to the news. So it was on a Friday night that I made the announcement. And the following week, I received a call from IKEA. From whom, at IKEA? Guy named Anders Westney. I hope I'm saying that right. He's with the business side of things as opposed to the legal side. He was saying that, well, the lawyers are there
到另一个网站上，那个网站上没有宜家的名字。至少，她很感激有这么多人对这个消息反应如此强烈。所以是在一个周五晚上我发布了公告。接下来的一周，我接到了宜家的电话。宜家的谁？一个叫安德斯·韦斯特尼（Anders Westney）的人。我希望我没念错。他是负责业务方面的，而不是法律方面的。他说，嗯，律师们在那里
to do their job, you know? And he also took a look at the letter of the CIS and the CIS letter. And he said that he didn't recognize I care in it. Really, he said that? Yes, he said that. He didn't have the spirit of the Bra, which is to make life better for everyone. And to that end, he told Jules that they wanted to find another way forward and try to figure
是为了做他们的工作，你知道的？他也看了那封停止侵权信。他说他在信里没认出宜家。真的，他这么说了？是的，他这么说了。他说那不符合品牌的精神，即让每个人的生活变得更好。为此，他告诉朱尔斯，他们想找到另一种前进的方式，并试图弄清楚
out how they can resolve things to come to some agreement. I seriously, when he called me, I was totally speechless. I was like, yeah, yeah. And inside me, I was screaming, you know, I was like, jumping, you know, if I could, I would, doing the Ikea dance. I was like crazy, you know, oh, and get this. As we're releasing this podcast, Jules is visiting Sweden and Holland, meeting face-to-face with representatives of Ikea. She's touring the Concept Center where their products are developed and then visiting
他们如何能解决问题并达成某种协议。说真的，当他打电话给我时，我完全说不出话来。我当时想，是啊，是啊。而在内心深处，我在尖叫，你知道，我当时想，跳起来，你知道，如果可以的话，我会做宜家之舞。我当时简直疯了，你知道，哦，还有这个。在我们发布这个播客时，朱尔斯正在访问瑞典和荷兰，与宜家的代表面对面会谈。她正在参观他们的产品开发概念中心，然后访问
the very homeland where it all began. Oh my god. It's like she's tarly bucket visiting Willy Wonka's talk at factory. Yes, I am. No, it's equal home. I mean, do you get a sense that IKEA would ever truly partner with jewels and make her some sort of minister of hacking or whatever. I mean, what I've been saying is like, I can't imagine IKEA could possibly endorse any individual hacker hacking on the whole,
这一切开始的故乡。天哪。这就像她是查理·巴克特（Charlie Bucket）参观威利·旺卡（Willy Wonka）的巧克力工厂。是的，我是。不，这太棒了。我的意思是，你觉得宜家会真正与朱尔斯合作，让她成为某种“改造部长”之类的吗？我的意思是，我一直在说的是，我无法想象宜家会认可任何个人改造者对整体进行改造，
it's just too risky, you know? I mean, if something goes wrong, I mean, it would basically be sanctioning what amounts to a misuse of their products. Even though I will say that misuse feels wonderful. I have to tell you, Jules, I, the feeling of hacking together my Ikea bid, well, I and Jonathan being,
这太冒险了，你知道？我的意思是，如果出了什么问题，我的意思是，这基本上就等于认可了对他们产品的误用。尽管我不得不说，误用感觉棒极了。我必须告诉你，朱尔斯，我，一起改造我的宜家床的感觉，嗯，我和乔纳森·比恩，
because it was really mostly him, but we, you know, created something. And that thing that we created is now something that I sleep on every night. Okay. It's just such a powerful feeling. There is actually a theory that one of the reasons why I care is so successful is because you have to make it yourself as in like you have to assemble it yourself. So if you are a certain sense of accomplishment or you know, I put together this Billy Bokeh level higher.
因为那主要是他做的，但我们，你知道，创造了一些东西。而我们创造的那个东西现在是我每天晚上睡觉的地方。好吧。这真是一种强大的感觉。实际上有一种理论认为，宜家之所以如此成功，原因之一是因为你必须自己动手，也就是说你必须自己组装它。所以如果你有一种成就感，或者你知道，我组装了这个比利书架。
Alright, the final touch. We're gonna put the mattress onto my new IKEA bed. Does it fit? Does it fit? It fits! Oh boy, it's a bed! It's a bed, it's a real bed! I'm not just a loser bachelor sleeping on the floor anymore! I mean an actual bed! Oh boy! I'm lying on my new bed! It's so comfortable! He still sounds like a crazy person.
好了，最后一步。我们要把床垫放到我的新宜家床上。它合适吗？它合适吗？它合适！天哪，这是一张床！这是一张床，一张真正的床！我不再是一个睡在地板上的失败单身汉了！我的意思是，一张真正的床！天哪！我躺在我的新床上！它太舒服了！他听起来还是像个疯子。
One more thing to add here. We also wrote to Anders Westney, the IKEA rep who reached out to Jewels' app saying, let's figure out a new way forward. He was very polite, but said that talking to us before talking to Jewels would be putting the cart before the horse. So in short, no comment. We'll have to wait for an update on IKEAHackers.net. Right, that's right. The steal is going to take us way up place to buy two things instead of six.
这里还要补充一点。我们也写信给了安德斯·韦斯特尼，那位联系朱尔斯·雅普的宜家代表，说让我们找出一种新的前进方式。他非常有礼貌，但表示在和朱尔斯谈话之前和我们谈话是本末倒置。所以简而言之，无可奉告。我们得等IKEAHackers.net的更新。没错，就是这样。这笔交易将带我们去一个买两样东西而不是六样东西的地方。
You are so smart. You're hacking the hack. Do you realize that you're hacking the hack? That's what hacking is. Oh, right. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sean Cole with Sam Green's fan Katie Mingle, Avery Tropham and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of
你太聪明了。你在改造这个改造。你意识到你在改造这个改造了吗？这就是改造的意义所在。哦，对了。《99% Invisible》本周由肖恩·科尔制作，山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特罗芬（Avery Trufelman）和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，制作于
the offices of Arxine, home with some very handsomely hacked, expedited shelves in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. The full 99% invisible experience isn't just this episode you're hearing, I post links to cool things and details about office hours and live shows on Facebook. I also do that and you know, make jokes on Twitter at Roman Mars along with our team Sam listens, Katie Mingle and Troubleman. We're also on Tumblr, Instagram Flickers, SoundCloud and Spotify, but you're always welcome at our place at 99bi.org. Radio Tapio.
Arxine的办公室，家里有一些非常帅气地改造过的、加急的书架，位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。完整的《99% Invisible》体验不仅仅是你听到的这一集，我还在Facebook上发布了很酷的东西的链接以及关于办公时间和现场演出的详细信息。我也这样做，你知道，在Twitter上@RomanMars和我们的团队山姆·利斯滕斯（Sam L listens）、凯蒂·明格尔和特罗布尔曼（Troubleman）一起开玩笑。我们也在Tumblr、Instagram、Flickr、SoundCloud和Spotify上，但随时欢迎你来我们的网站99pi.org。广播塔皮奥。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。